there is also an
unbelievable amount of crime happening
in blue cities right now you know it we
cover it all the time by the way in
Chicago you know remember a couple weeks
ago they voted out that lunatic
Beetlejuice over there Lori Lightfoot
well it turns out that they have since
voted in probably even more of a far
left Progressive so Chicago is just
going to keep getting worse but the
worst of the worst as you guys know is
San Francisco San Francisco has
completely collapsed it is not a
coincidence that San Francisco was once
run by at the time mayor Gavin Newsom
now governor of California Gavin Newsom
there was a horrific murder on the
streets of California of San Francisco
about two days ago no I think it was
this weekend so it was about three days
ago uh cash app founder bobbly I think
is 43 years old was stabbed to death in
San Francisco here's CBS covering what
happened
tonight friends and family are
confirming what many fear the 43 year
old man San Francisco police found
stabbed here on Main Street early
Tuesday morning is well-known Tech
executive Bob Lee the father of two was
Chief product officer at cryptocurrency
startup mobile coin before that he
worked with former Twitter CEO Jack
Dorsey at Square Dorsey today called his
death heartbreaking Lee would later
create the mobile payment service cash
app burnt Twitter CEO Elon Musk
responded to news of the killing by
taking a swipe at the city a violent
crime in SF he said is horrific
okay it's an unbelievable murder look
the guy 43 years old what's interesting
about this uh is that well Jack Dorsey
from Twitter comments about it but Jack
Dorsey was one of the main people at
Twitter there who was pumping money into
the things and defending all of the
horrific ideas that have destroyed what
once was a great City San Francisco and
I went to it for the first time about 15
years ago was was absolutely beautiful
gorgeous thriving flourishing and now it
is just everything the reverse of that
uh Elon musk's comments are completely
right the amount of security he has to
have at the Twitter offices which is in
the midst of a zombie apocalypse and
what's interesting about this story
particularly is that this this poor guy
he had fled San Francisco yeah he used
to live in San Francisco you know where
he lived now Miami he had moved to
Florida to enjoy some Freedom he was
back there doing some business and and
he got murdered on the streets
foreign
[Music]